il y en avait deux des filles avait il y
avait un dc technique et ya laissé
architectural donc le défi technique
c'est effectivement c'est c'est
réinvestir donc un bâtiment tertiaire
dans un bâtiment qui étaient des années
70 72 13 anciens peu large
donc on a eu l'idée très rapidement avec
pierre-jean de construire cette atrium
donc d'investir la cour intérieure qui
était une cour qui est un parking qui
n'étaient pas utiles utilisé pour
l'utiliser en lieu de à la fois de
convivialité est à la fois donc en
espaces de circulation ce qui a permis
de redonner de la liberté dans les
espaces existants et cette ouverture et
cette transparence qu'on a plus qu on a
pu retrouver nous vraiment le projet on
l'a conçu de l'intérieur vers
l'extérieur et après donc aujourd'hui
comme tous les bâtiments modernes donc
se doit d'être performant techniquement
donc on a travaillé sur l' enveloppe
donc thermique donc d'une première pas
donc sur la façade très exposés qui la
façade derrière nous donc la phase est
courbé on est on a des vitrages très
performant avec des bricelets etc qui
sont aux commandes qui sont en commande
sur une station météo donc pour le
confort intérieur et on en a profité
bien sûr de données
une image nouvelle et moderne de l'âge
moderne du site donc tout en respectant
le lieu la ville dans son histoire donc
on à la fois jouer sur la transparence
et puis à la fois sur le sur la pierre
puisque le dans son étude ville de
pierre donc sur la rentrée sur la rue
courbet on a travaillé avec une mode et
nature spéciale texture une pierre qu'on
a retrouvé qu'on a recherché mais avec
un apu l'équivalent de cette fameuse
paire de chalut et on a cherché les
équivalences et retrouver un peu cette
idée là ce qui fait qu effectivement
cette façade pour lesquelles on a
rajouté deux étages les bisontins s'en
sont pas aperçus en fait et on a presque
ça toujours été là c'est le fait partie
d'une réussite ça n'aurait pas été plus
simple de démolir et de reconstruire sur
sûr c'était l'idée l'idée au lit d
origine ce que font tous les ce que font
tous les sièges en fait de france c'est
à dire qu'il sait il s'expatrie
cependant les summer vivons dans les
îles vont dans les zones où dans les
zones extérieures il abandonne les
centres villes là c'était double c'était
un peu double punition parce qu'il a
fallu sortir le puisque le bâtiment
était en étaient en activité
donc il a fallu sortir les 250 personnes
les relogés pendant deux ans et demi et
ensuite les réintroduire donc forcément
ça tout ça un surcoût d'une dizaine de
millions d'euros
ça compte
sur l'ensemble du budget de l'opération
le liban dans le cahier des charges
avait d'autres contraintes
imposer il fallait obtenir le maximum de
surface
donc on a créé quand même sur les 7000
m² à 1200 mètres carrés en extension et
il fallait créer un bâtiment tertiaire
qui soit souple et modulable
donc ça c'était la règle de base est
confortable thermiquement thermique
visuel qualité de l'air également et
puis acoustique donc ça c'était
principal cahier des charges après on a
eu toute liberté pour agir local ou un
concours ça que cinq équipes donc je
crois qu'il ya deux projets qui avait
pris l'option de créer ce site atrium et
puis de redistribuer en fait ça a permis
effectivement donc nous avons été
choisis et ça permet effectivement de
créer de métamorphoser je veux dire
j'emploie le terme parce que c'était les
gens qui ont qui ont travaillé avant sur
le site et qu'ils travaillent qui arrive
aujourd'hui ne s'y reconnaissent même
pas intervenir c'était vraiment une
métamorphose du défi après faire
travailler des entreprises
franc-comtoises sur le projet pour
une bande qui est né en franche comté
ça faisait aussi partie du cadet déjà
alors tout à fait donc ça c'était le
choix des entreprises on l'a fait en
accord avec avec le maître d'ouvragé
donc on a vraiment été suivi à ce niveau
là c'est vrai qu'il ya des clients de la
caisse mais peu 95% des entreprises ou
sur les trentaine d'autres cuisson des
entreprises locales
et ça c'est une réussite fantastique
également pour le projet parce que ça a
permis une en plus les entreprises qui
sont locales qui se connaissent un peu
tous donc ça a permis de créer un lien
le ligne de liant entre les entreprises
et c'était un enjeu important une fierté
de pour chaque est pour chacune de
travailler sur ce site là donc à un
moment du chantier tout le monde avait
placardé sur l'échafaudage sais pas si
vous vous souvenez
je ne cherche qu on ait mis tout le
monde avait placardé son identité donc
c'était vraiment une fierté personnelle
et ça je crois que c'est vraiment bien
parce qu'en la sortie c'est vrai qu'on
nous reproche souvent de manquer de
professionnalisme de manquer de
compétences locales
hélas
preuve en est on a prouvé qu
effectivement notamment avec le pool les
habillages de façade ont été réalisés
par l'entreprise obligèrent on n'a pas à
rougir les plus grands travaux parisien